I had three goals absolutely beautiful I
was kind of new in the industry so I was
aware that I probably couldn't have
pulled one of these goals on a night out
you know like and then there was three
of them and they was all on their knees
about to do play with my dingling and I
I just had nothing it was just like it
was like a noodle you know pushing rope
uphill it was just absolutely nothing
welcome to this episode of extraordinary
lives the lad Bible podcast and today we
are joined by Danny Danny welcome to the
show thanks for having me great to have
you here awesome to be back and um if
you could just to anyone watching or
listening give a little introduction to
who you were uh my name's Danny D
um I'm an adult Entertainer I suppose a
porn star I suppose people would call it
um yeah been in the business for just
over 15 years I think
um yeah out of the UK doing my thing
that's pretty much me okay great well
let's let's get into it in a bit more
detail because
I suppose for a lot of people
your job probably looks like to a lot of
young men a dream job
and one of the things I think a lot of
people won't know is how you actually go
about getting into that
yeah I mean when I got started
completely different to now
um you know just back to as in
technology times you know there wasn't
sort of Twitter and stuff I think there
was one Forum when I started which was
like an adult producer's forum right um
when was that
17 years ago I think I was like 18 so I
was super young super new
um and it was a lot difficult back then
there was a lot more Productions as in
uh television X and TV start Playboy TV
um and yeah it was just quite difficult
to get started really
um so you kind of had to get yourself
out there
um find a girl that would kind of work
with you things like that but and was it
something you were trying to get into
like did you know you wanted to go into
it yeah I actively tried to pursue porn
um and say it was quite tough to get
into I did a few Solo shoots and things
like that to kind of get started and my
original start was to go to swinging
clubs and that was kind of where the
idea began if you like um I went to a
swinging club when I was like 18.
um I need to see if I had the confidence
and could do it and uh yeah some guy
asked me to have sex with his wife
and uh offered me 50 euros to film it 50
Euros so was it not anything it was here
but they lived in France
um so yeah it wasn't just that yeah yeah
so I ended up shooting with his wife and
uh yeah they offered me to go and shoot
in France with them at their home and um
paid me like 50 Euros or 150 Euros I
think to travel out there and shoot wow
um and that was kind of this the idea
began you know it was like I could get
paid for this and was that I mean
at that age was that not intimidating
it was more confusing the fact that he
wasn't going to punch me in the face yes
and I'd like because I wasn't from that
world of you know wife sharing and stuff
like that you know but I worked on a
building site so I was quite
um you know open to most things you know
guilty of the occasional wolf whistle
here and there and you know but um as I
say so I was quite open to that sort of
stuff and um yeah it was more intriguing
really that the whole sort of world of
it and and so he flew over to are they
through flew over to France and you did
that a couple of times yeah so I was
booked to do I think one or two scenes
um and yeah it was super strange I was
really nervous
um and I flew there
met the couple and was staying at their
house with them and stuff and I remember
we just drove out to some like Woods or
something and we shot a scene out there
and at the back of the car and he gave
me the money and was like oh you know
that's it and
I was just blown away counting the money
being like this is amazing like you know
this is yeah this is a thing and then he
was like yeah if you want to do it again
let us know and I was like yeah I'm good
to go and we kind of just shot another
one there and then and oh wow what yeah
because it's literally 10 minutes after
I was like what you'd pay me every time
that I'll do that he's like yeah I'll
pay you each tax I was like cool let's
go again like um and yeah that was the
kind of the start of transaction if you
like money for sex and
that was um when the kind of idea opened
of actually this this could be a viable
thing for me so how do you how do you as
a young man that doesn't know how the
industry Works how do you transition a
man that you've met in a swinging club
from France to a profession so a lot of
just networking really trying to as I
say there used to be a forum uh back in
the day
um bgfd or something but yeah there was
some forum who used to go on there and I
could then post you know I've done this
work for this company I then had photos
or screenshots of video footage of me
working with a female to sort of show to
other producers that you know I could do
the job if you like albeit that I'm new
um then I had some sort of CV to be able
to promote myself and message other
performers of a talent producers and
stuff and this is this this is a weird
question to ask somebody but you know
this is what we're going to be talking
about uh I've heard you talk before
about a trip to Germany uh and you know
you you
you've got the confidence that you had
something that would set you apart right
yeah so the way the whole kind of thing
I didn't realize I had a big penis until
yeah I went to this last holiday when I
was like 17 18. um
I just you know I was quite shy as a kid
you know I don't didn't use your rhinos
didn't you know sort of have group
showers and stuff so kind of never
really knew anything
um and every time you see porn it sort
of looked about the same I was like yeah
there's a big dick that's about it right
um and I was a builder uh went to
Germany for the World Cup I believe and
uh yeah one of my buddies saw my penis
and told all my friends and was just
like dude you need to you need to do
something with this get off the building
site you know just be an underwear model
or something for Calvin Klein like that
doesn't really I don't think I've got
the body for that and there was just the
whole holiday just a a roasted of jokes
of things I could do you know you could
be a male gigolo you could be a porn
star you could do this you know and that
was kind of what sparked the idea
um right and as I say I kind of cut that
bit off but yeah I had to then
work outfit of something that I was able
to do you know um and so when you then
when you're then talking to these
producers and you're on these forums
showing you so you've then got the kind
of the beginnings of a portfolio like
photos of a scene or whatever or a video
I've seen and then do they is the fact
that you had a big penis one of the
things that would make them give you a
chance in the first place or is it your
attitude or your I think the penis
helped get me through the door
um I'm not gonna lie
um but again what a sentence
but then it just kind of comes down to
you know there's like an old saying
you're only as good as your last scene
yeah um and that kind of is a lot more
important when you're starting out you
know you kind of need to deliver really
good scenes on your first ones to kind
of get invited back and and do well but
as I say it was a completely different
industry to what it is now you know
where there is content creators and only
fans Etc you know you can easily set up
a page and get this CV of scenes and
stuff quite easily now to approach
companies and say hey I'm doing all this
work I've gained all this experience
whereas back when I started you know
getting someone to take a chance on you
it's expensive you know they've got to
hire the crew the girl the location
everything else and they could just book
a guy that they know is reliable was
regular so starting out as a new guy it
can be difficult just to kind of get
that initial break you know someone just
to give you the chance and then when you
get that break like what you've just
described there like sound sounds like a
lot of pressure so you you get given
that break and they've booked a crew
booked all this sort of stuff and you
get in there as a young guy that's not
massively experienced yet like were you
confident on your performing abilities
or were you was there an anxiety there I
think there's there was always there
always is an anxiety there I still get
nervous today oh wow like every scene I
get nervous I get sweaty I get you know
um so I think there is always that
nervousness and I think that's a good
thing um you kind of use it to your
advantage but I think I just didn't
realize the magnitude of what was on the
line at the time you know I was just
literally having fun and I think that
was the best thing that it could have
been because if I had kind of put into
perspective how much was on the line for
me to have a good scene it might have
got to my head but I just was kind of
having fun along the way and I
definitely feel that helped fair enough
and and at that point when you started
were you kind of going
uh you know this is this is a dream I'm
telling everyone I can or were you like
going okay I'm not going to tell that
because now obviously if you do a scene
or an only fans or something things are
just on the internet forever but I guess
back then 17 years ago Pawn was still
probably something that you had to pay
for you know before the kind of
streaming and all those services so yeah
if you'd wanted to keep it a bit quieter
I guess it would have been slightly more
possible than it is now it kind of was a
bit easier to keep quiet I didn't sort
of shout about it right from the get-go
my sort of immediates know my friends
and family
um but yeah it wasn't something that I
kind of showered from the rooftops on
I've always had a weird thing I don't
like the word porn star as well you know
okay it's a strange definition of a job
isn't it it's a strange title
um you know it's like
yeah I don't know if you worked in
movies you wouldn't call yourself a
movie star you're an actor right I see
what you mean I mean it's so it's a
strange thing so so what do you prefer I
don't really know I really I suppose
adult performer sure performer but yeah
it's um it's a strange one as I say
everyone knows it as a porn star but
when you're starting out it's that thing
of you can't call yourself a porn star
because you've only done 10 scenes or 20
you know what level do you then become a
porn star as opposed to an actor and
um or an adult actor rather so yeah it's
quite a weird dynamic when you're
starting out just trying to find out
where you sit in that yeah and like you
say there when you when you're first
starting you know I've heard you say
before you
I think this is okay to ask about tell
me if you don't wanna I've heard you say
before um on other things that you
started doing gay porn is that correct
yeah I did go for pay yeah yeah and what
what does gay for pay mean
um it's basically where you're prepared
to work with a guy even though you're
not maybe gay or that orientated
um so yeah that was that's kind of how I
sort of you know got my sort of start if
you like I sort of did um solo stuff
which was just me performing on my own
and then it kind of graduated would you
do that sat next to someone
Etc
um and yeah that was the kind of
progression for me it wasn't something I
really wanted to pursue as a career but
I was quite aware that you know
um it would do well for me in that sense
of and is that a common thing do a lot
of male porn stars go sorry no no I feel
free yeah no it's just not it's not
offensive okay do a lot of male
performers go down that route
um back in the day it used to be the in
the older days there was a lot more
prolific performers who had done sort of
scenes that way and I think there used
to be a kind of a theory behind it if
you could get hard for this you can get
hard for that you know you can do this
you can do that you know you should just
be a sexual Gladiator you should be able
to just do the scenes and
um
but yeah so it was a bit different back
in the day um and as I say personal
preference wasn't really kind of thought
about in that sense for me personally
um but as I got older it was definitely
something I just focused on what I
wanted to do within myself so are you
able to like obviously you only know how
you feel you don't know how other people
feel and other people only know how they
feel but are you able to
form like the control you have over your
body must be different to other people
because
other people might not be able to
perform unless they're directly sexually
aroused yeah can you make yourself
aroused for anything so yeah I kind of
see it as a it's very I worked out quite
early on you can't have a thing you know
you're kind of like a fetish you know
say for example I get hard over big
boobs right because you might not always
be working with a girl that has big
boobs yeah so I kind of just had to work
out something that works for me
something that I can always think about
always relate to and and sort of get
excited about
um so for me yeah weirdly I went for
protruding bone
um because everyone has bones you know
so it doesn't matter you can always find
it in the in the wrist you know there's
bones in the wrist or in the ribs or the
hips and things like that so if I kind
of feel the body and I feel them sort of
parts of people
um I find that works for me wow that's
fascinating it's strange but it's
something that everyone has so you can
just apply it to any scene apply to
anything really and did you train
yourself into that or was it just a
natural thing you like I think it just
it just sort of happened I think I felt
someone's hip once and was like oh that
feels nice and then it kind of developed
onto the rip and I was like oh yeah you
can feel that there and I think you know
just trying to find something because as
I say I've been in scenarios where it
hasn't worked I haven't had a fallback
thing
um I remember one scene I
I came very close to failing
um I was I had three girls absolutely
beautiful I was kind of new in the
industry so I was aware that I probably
couldn't have pulled one of these goals
on a night out you know like and then
there was three of them and they was all
on their knees about to do play with My
Ding-A-Ling and I I just had nothing it
was just like it was like a noodle you
know pushing rope uphill it was just
absolutely nothing and I was just inside
my head going come on buddy what are you
doing like this is a dream come true
like why and I just got so nervous and I
like thought myself out of it you know
and once it's in your head it's it's in
your head because now all you're
thinking about is yeah what do you do in
that kind of situation just take a break
best thing rather than just persevering
for it and then the noodle penis just
flop around just take two minutes and
just say cool just need a minute just
gonna get some air have a sandwich
whatever you need to do
um and then just yeah refocus rather
than
persevering trying to be like yeah be
okay it'll be okay and in that case it
was okay yeah I think I took about 10
minutes of struggling and realizing
crying inside before I was like just
just give me a minute and then come back
to the scene and do you feel when I mean
I'm not sure if you've had that happen
many times or that was the only time but
could you feel a sense it like a
mounting tension in terms of course yeah
it's it's a horrendous place to be as as
a male performer um there's a lot of
pressure on that sense you know you know
all the crew are waiting no matter how
much everyone says oh it's fine take
your time you know they've got a school
run to do or they've got to pick their
kids up or they've got a home to go to
or they've got dinner and all the
location's only booked till five or you
know you know there is all this pressure
so as much as everyone says it's okay
and it is okay
um you're aware that it's hindering the
day you're sort of slowing it down so
it's a strange thing especially as a
producer now we kind of have to
sometimes deal with it and as I say it's
the human body it's natural we don't you
know don't expect you to be a robot and
perform on command but on the same sense
you know to perform you want to be good
at your job and you want to kind of just
make the day as easy as possible for
everyone so
um yeah there can be a lot of pressure
on that but as I say thinking
just knowing yourself and knowing your
body is kind of the best way to be about
it you know if you know that you're not
100 take a minute take a minute and one
of the one of the sort of those industry
rumors like it's one of those urban
legends is that thing about well uh
they're referred to as fluffers so that
there's a group of people that can help
you yeah prepare for the scene like that
is that is that something that exists in
reality it's not no I mean back in the
day it was a thing that's where it came
from like 70s 80s yeah right okay again
you've got to look at how technology was
different you know so back then they was
on film cameras so film was expensive
there wasn't alt cut delete that we'll
redo it you know they was actually
filming on film
um so the guy had to be ready you know
there was a sound waiting on wood
um and it's the same thing you're
waiting on the guy you know so they just
needed that guy to be ready to go so
when they got the cameras already and
set up and running to speed they would
have a fluffer on the wings getting that
guy prepped making sure he was A-Okay so
that the main stars makeup wasn't
getting affected or anything and then
they could just
go ahead with the with the scene
um but obviously now things have changed
we have digital cameras we don't shoot
on film we're able to just cart we're
able to delete we're able to restart
um so yeah fluffers aren't really a a
necessity or a needed thing anymore so
fair enough but as fun as it would be
just to have staff just to suck penis
that would be amazing sure it's not a
thing unfortunately and what about the
opposite side of the story you've just
told us so you know on one side you're
saying they're about the noodle penis
but what about the opposite side where
presumably you know I don't know how
exactly it works and you I'm sure you
can Enlighten us but if you've got a
scene that you're doing presumably
there's a series of things that you want
to get through uh what happens if you
are halfway through that and you're like
oh God you know like
premature yes
um yeah again can happen
um you can get overexcited or
overzealous with yourself
um but again it's just taking that
moment I think when you when you do this
as a job you can kind of start to learn
a lot about your body you can learn
signs
techniques or things that kind of maybe
give you an influence that you're about
to prematurely ejaculate or something
um and a lot of it's just distraction
you know for me if I'm doing something
that feels good and I feel like I'm
gonna I just stop doing it you know it's
just don't keep doing the thing so just
change it up and you know when I first
started off I'd be like okay cut and
walk off the set and then that would
kind of stop it happening but then I've
realized as I got a bit older as a
performer that now that means we have to
go all the way back to that position we
have to then continue and then go back
from that whereas if I just move to
something else you know say maybe change
my position in or go down on her or just
change the whole element we don't have
to make a hard cut and keep the scene
flowing it keeps more passion in it it
keeps the scene flowing better and just
keeps the performers into it but just
gives me a minute to calm down what's
actually excited me
tricks of the trade there you go and
usually when people sleep with each
other in in society unless it's a kind
of one that's done thing there's some
kind of emotional connection going on so
when you're a young lad and you're
meeting these you know so as you
describe beautiful women and you're
sleeping with them at the beginning was
there any ever any confusing feelings of
emotion in it or from the beginning for
you was it like it's a separate thing it
was quite separate and I think again
when you sort of see it in your head you
know the only sort of reference point
you have is when you've had sex with
someone in the normal world and
generally there always is some sort of
connection some sort of emotional
connection even if it's just you fancy
the person
um when you go on to a porn set it's
quite sterile in that fact
um there isn't like you know there's
banter and there's humor but it's not
like a flirty Vibe you know we're not
here on a date you know that's quite
clear that it is quite a professional
thing we're here to make a product
um and although there is chemistry
within the scene and there is passion
and stuff on the day it's not set out
like that from the get-go you know from
the morning there's not flirty bit of
banter with the girl
um so it does it sounds cold but it does
feel a bit more transactional rather
than just like if you met someone at a
club and there's a bit of a Chase
element to it okay um so where that
chase element's kind of removed it is
kind of a a Level Playing Field you kind
of both know what we're here to do you
both want to give as best as you can
um so yeah there is less confusion in
that sense that makes sense and does
that follow on to like you know when you
see scenes where there's group sex going
on you you know when you the way the
piece is created is to to make it look
like it's this thing where everyone's
having this fantastic time all enjoying
themselves but actually for the
performers is it much more like it does
it feel like a job
um at times it's a weird one sometimes
it feels like a job and sometimes it
it's the most amazing job in the world
it doesn't feel like you're working at
all
um and as I say in the group scenes
there's different ways of looking at it
you know there's a benefit of actually
you've got to do less work because
there's more performers the camera can
only film certain amount of stuff at
once you know so there is more people to
take the edge off and
but on the same terms it's there's more
people's there's more people that you've
got to interact with and as I say you
can kind of just flow with them each
scene you know sort of see where it
takes you but and then and then with
with the previous piece where you're
talking about the emotional distance was
you know clear from the beginning what
about the other side of it then so
that's the professional side but in your
private life
at the beginning did it was it hard to
farm relationships outside of work based
on what you were doing yeah
um it's quite hard to have a
relationship or there has to be a lot of
understanding a lot of communication a
lot of trust
um maybe when I was younger I probably
wasn't the best at being as open and
honest as I should be and I think the
longer you're in the industry and have
relationships within it you learn more
about yourself and relationships and
honesty being the key
um and I say yeah it can be difficult to
date
um I'd say when I first started in the
industry I found that I could
um you know I could get sex for example
someone would be happy to sleep with a
porn star just to take it off the bucket
of the store okay put it in the girls
chat you know I did this whatever but
they wouldn't want to go to the cinema
with you or have a date if you like you
know they wouldn't allow themselves to
sort of
fall for you or going at that sort of
romantic level so that that kind of was
a bit difficult at the start but I think
just knowing why you're in it and what
you want to do and remaining happy and
true to yourself kind of so I guess at
that point your desire to be successful
in that industry was overruling yes and
no I mean it's one it's a desire to be
successful but I think two just knowing
my truth and being happy with myself
yeah this is what I want to be and if
someone's gonna love me for me then I
have to be honest with myself and with
that person and say look this is what I
do this is why I do it it doesn't
necessarily mean I'm cheating on you it
doesn't necessarily mean I'm [__]
everything I want but this is my career
you're more than welcome to come on set
and see how sort of cold it is at times
and sterile it can be it's not what
people perceive
um but I think having that Honesty
within a relationship is the key bit to
making it work yes it is such a
difficult thing you know it's not normal
for your partner to go and have a blow
job and then go and have sex with
another person yeah it's not the most
normal common thing
um so I think having honesty for that
with your partner telling them about it
the wise and understanding you as a
person
kind of is the the best approach yeah
because um well just before we came in
here I met your lovely wife so it's
worked for you that's it um yeah it's
again it is a case of being honest and
as I say we won't like you know there's
difficult times to it there's Parts
where you know you have to kind of
really you know be open and honest with
each other but for the most part as I
say I think you can clear a lot of stuff
before
um before it becomes an issue yeah and I
mean every relationship has difficulties
as well of course of course
um and I think that's it it's just with
ours there is that added element of
having sex with someone else today
um yes how are you how you bring that
into play but yeah sure okay
um as you're progressing through the um
career
um one of the things that uh is often
said is that the the there's more women
than men because there's more
heterosexual male viewers of porn than
any of the demographic I believe is what
I read I don't know if you would agree
or disagree yeah would you say that the
um
the the power dynamic in that industry
is is do the women have more power based
on the fact that the men are more
disposable or or not see it's a
difficult thing because I'd say there's
more women uh come through the industry
and guys that tends to be less of us but
again a good guy kind of stays around
for longer has a bit more longevity
um and I think it's just literally
because no one cares no one cares about
the guys right no one really is watching
porn for the dude I'm sure there is a
few but most of the time they're there
for the girl
um so I think for the producers points
or the fans points as long as the guy
can deliver his part of the deal they
don't really care too much who he is
okay
um and the girl obviously changes like
flavors it's like ice cream you know
people want to try different flavors
they'll have a flavor of the month and
then it might change I think that's why
you sort of see a rotation of girls and
stuff some make it and will obviously be
around for a number of years
um and then some sort of kind of come
and go um but with the guys do you find
Once the guy kind of breaks through his
sort of stick around for a few years you
know that makes sense so as you start to
get more successful in your career
um you know at what age did you tell
family members
I told my family straight straight off
the bat yeah have you always had quite
an open like discourse with them uh yeah
always uh mum and stuff has always been
super open super friendly so I told her
when I first did my shoot and was like
oh my God you'll never guess what I'm
going you know and uh yeah she was super
supportive yeah so I'm going to France
this guy's getting me to bang his wife
oh even that one even oh wow right from
the get-go and uh yeah so there was
there were some tough points you know
trying to think about if I said that to
mine the 18th what would have happened
you must have had a very very open
relationship yeah super open
um and as I say it sounds funny now but
I mean there was times where I wasn't
doing great you know I was really trying
to get work and I wasn't having much
work coming through the gate and you
know I remember one month having to ring
my mum and being like look I haven't got
rent you know can I borrow some money to
pay rent and my mum came down and sat in
my living room and was like like had the
chat you know maybe it's time you get a
job you know maybe you could look at
getting a trade on getting something
behind you you know I don't think this
is gonna work you know long term you
know and how long into it was that like
it was a couple of years yeah it was a
few years into it
um so yeah it was a struggle you know it
was tough to get through it wasn't and I
remember just sort of being so confused
by this why would I no I'm not stopping
like that's ridiculous like you're
you're wrong you know and as I say it
took a lot to keep going and sort of
make it work and pay um so what was the
point where you I mean it might be
several years later or maybe it still
hasn't happened because of how you are
as a person but was there a point where
you went okay no this is this is me set
now like I can do this and it's gonna be
okay yeah I think um when browsers came
along uh they changed my life
um they're an amazing company to work
for and when they came they kind of put
you know a real stamp on what we was
doing you know really kind of gave me
the sort of push to work for the best
companies do the best that I could do in
my performing and stuff like that um and
I'd say that was when it changed that
was when I really had a oh okay this is
cool now you know they they got me a
visa to work in America took me to
America took me to Vegas La
um all over the world Argentina you know
just countless places and countries and
that was when I started to see the call
element and was like oh wow okay now
this is this is a viable life choice you
know so would they were they just a
production company or a management
company so they're a product yeah yeah
um uh yeah a large website Who basically
contracted me 10 11 years ago now
and yeah when they came along it was it
really changed and I would say that
international travel
um working with new Crews bigger name
girls you know things like that was
really where it elevated especially from
from being from the UK
um obviously there's a lot larger
industry in the US
um so for me when they kind of came over
and scooped me up
um that was when I was like oh oh wow
this is this has got a bit of legs now
you know hi guys it's Connor here from
Lab rival and we're taking a quick break
to talk about this episode's sponsor our
friends at manscapes manscapes are here
to save us because it's Father's Day
just around the corner I've got to be
honest with you I've installed anything
at Father's Day yet it's always a
nightmare knowing what to get my dad you
look around the shops and it's the same
stuff every year socks whiskey bottles
golf balls the same stuff you get
everywhere so this year manscapes has
got the total package for the Father
Figure in your life my dad isn't getting
any younger and with age of course comes
hair in all the wrong places I'm talking
nose is everywhere dad I love you but
you've got to keep on top of it better
which is why I'm looking at the
performance package 4.0 the performance
package 4.0 comes with a lawnmower
trimmer to level up the grooming routine
there's also the weed whacker 2.0 which
is especially designed for nose and ear
trimming and in the package you get
deodorant toner briefs and a travel bag
too eight million men around the world
use manscapes I'm one of them I've used
all these products before and would
definitely recommend them as a Father's
Day gift for your dad step dad Granddad
whoever get 20 off and free shipping
with the code minutes at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping just by
using the code minutes this Father's Day
at manscape.com and then from that
period when you uh suddenly you went
from kind of like looking around for
jobs to suddenly people giving you jobs
um were there any sort of unusual
stories that you remember from that
period of time yeah there was a lot of
tricky things you know as I say just
when you're starting out you get so many
offers of things to do this and things
to do that you know I did a few sex
party things where I just you know kind
of needed money it was adultish work so
I went to a party one where I was I was
put in a box so it was like a big wooden
box and there was like holes in the box
of marigolds kind of attached and then I
got in the Box naked and there was like
four of these at this party and these
guests could just put their hands in the
box and we was in the inside and these
marigolds would just be in there
touching us wow and yes we'd do like
three hour shifts in the box at some
rich dude's party lots of people just
wanted to touch a naked man in a box
well there was some there was two girls
two guys yeah and we were just in a box
um we'd do a couple of hour shifts in
there it was kind of strange it wasn't
even necessarily like overtly sexual it
was just touching yeah it was no sex
work or anything yeah I was just a party
piece in a rich man's party wow as I say
it was sounds kind of like eyes wide
shut that yeah that's it so there were
some strange things on the way up that
like I say It was kind of a all right
yeah I'll give that a go um and the the
the the other thing that obviously is
the kind of like um
you know we we did a video with you
before
um and the comments were pretty funny in
that section it was like lots of people
were saying stuff like oh I recognize
this guy he came and did the plumbing
well I was out my wife told me and you
know that kind of procedure yeah the gym
teacher and all that sort of stuff but
obviously one of the kind of um
the jokes around that industry is the
the the the story set up so the washing
machine's broken and all that kind of
thing like is that is that accurate have
you done a lot of things like that with
those loads yeah that's my bread and
butter right so the kind of stories are
based on like coming around to fix up
all sorts yeah you've got the pizza
delivery guy or the plumber or your
stepsister's stuck in the washing
machine yeah you know sure like there
was a weird phase a couple of years ago
where people were stocking walls that
was that was so strange in walls in
walls so it's like someone you'd I'd
have to build a set with like a fake
wall and a hole in and there would be
like a girl trapped halfway through the
wall
um stuck yeah that was a super strange
little niche because was there a story
around how she'd ended up there or was
that sometimes and sometimes she would
just be in the wall okay um but again
you'd get this order and it's like oh
we're gonna shoot one of these scenes
and I'm like okay hang on like where am
I gonna film this like I can't just go
to someone's house and start hammering a
hole in the wall you know so then you
have to like start okay right we're
gonna have to build a set build a fake
wall
um which is actually something that
you've kind of become known for isn't it
because you have become known as someone
that does these slightly more um
more interesting and complex stories and
set builds I try and do the the bigger
builds yeah and the more interesting
plots and stuff as I say the the bread
and butter of the you know pizza
delivery guy or the plumber or whatever
that's kind of that's always there but
yeah we try and do a big featurette or a
big production series type things to
follow and yeah you showed me some
pictures of it on your phone before
where you built like a it was basically
like the inside of a spaceship a
spaceship here yeah it was amazing like
basically anyone I bumped into for the
last couple months has seen pictures so
so how does that stuff come about
um so again uh the company Digital
Playground wanted to make a big Space
movie
um and then we worked out a script
basically what they wanted and then we
had to produce it so ended up shooting
in a nuclear bunker
um and a few other cool locations
um and then we basically had to put it
together so couldn't find a decent
spaceship so we had to build one
um thankfully got a studio so we could
start building it was a labor of love I
think it took me just under two months
wow to and you were building it over
Christmas you said building it over
Christmas yeah my partner was not happy
on Christmas day when I was like kid's
done with all the yeah could drink and I
could just knit down Studio for a couple
of hours I was like well no it's
Christmas Day like I was like ah boxing
day
um but yeah you just it becomes
obsessive you know it's something that I
really enjoy the building side of it
um and uh yeah just kind of being
creative with no budget is is really fun
and there's and does so do you enjoy the
scripting in a story as well yeah the
script in the story is fun I think I
most enjoy building the worlds you know
like the taking it from the script and
then creating it into an actual thing
um whether that's being working out
where we're going to shoot it and using
the back of a kitchen or a nightclub or
something to be some area or whether it
being building a full spaceship and
trying to build a hibernation chamber or
whatever I think that's the bit I enjoy
the most of of putting it from paper
into reality and working out how we're
going to do this for a cheap budget and
you know that's the thing we don't have
Hollywood budgets we don't have that
level
um and it's the same with the costumes
and all those kind of yeah a lot of the
stuff we have make we make a lot of it a
lot of it is like a labor of love you
know you probably wouldn't realize
watching one of these big parodies the
sort of levels that go into it but as I
say it's um yeah the only way you can
kind of do it without spending loads of
money is is making it yourself I mean
all of them walk around Ikea and just
turn things upside down so like I know
you know the cutlery trades for example
turn that upside down spray it great
looks like space walls and you just
stick them all up there's tons of little
things so I enjoy that sort of challenge
we should advertise it for that yeah are
you building a spaceship Ikea flat pack
spaceships can you imagine there you go
yeah it's 17 men to build it you know
four and a half years and do you have
any any issues with you know so usually
in films obviously what they do is
they'll have say when you're talking
about doing you told me before about a
dystopian future one you've done and
we're talking there about sci-fi one and
obviously you've got aliens and
creatures like that but does the nature
of your work make it more complicated it
does
um yeah so there's obviously legal
restrictions about certain elements of
sci-fi and fantasy
um so that's something that you often
have to play into
um into your films any more details on
that yeah so for example one example I
did a Power Rangers parody back in the
day and there is I think his name's
goldar he looks a monkey with like a
suit of armor type thing yes well I
played goldar right that's great um I
had to wear a giant monkey suit with a
suit of armor like the two worst things
you want to perform in is one a suit of
armor and two is a monkey suit but
combined it was awful
um so yeah I was that with a blue face
and um
obviously I had to have sex with one of
the Power Rangers so there was then well
you can't have a mythical ape have sex
with a human so that doesn't work so we
had to literally add in a line that I'm
100 human for legal reasons oh what
because otherwise it'd be classed as
like bestiality yeah so oh wow we had to
then say that he wasn't an ape he was a
humanoid ape or whatever and so yeah you
have to kind of find your technicality
oh right that's interesting so you're
not even allowed so obviously bestiality
is legal but you're not even allowed to
you can't dress up as a gorilla no it's
obviously a human you can't yeah pretend
that you're doing that I think so yeah
it's just a very gray area of you can't
do um an alien or a spirit or an entity
or something you know wow it's um God
I'm quite surprised it's legislation
against ghosts it's kind of a strange
one isn't it you know where do you draw
the line so we always err on the side of
caution and things like that just
because you know but these things always
create their own challenges as I say
we've done like humanoids and alien type
things where you have full body paint
and just that in itself with the nature
of what we're doing yeah you know body
paint gets everywhere and it's it's
annoying to work with but it's kind of
there's only one way you can make
someone look blue or green and you know
and how does how does
um so stuff like that when you're in
sets are there's High concept builds or
there's characters or
um you know costumes that obviously
sounds for that industry fairly High
budget so how did it change when only
funds came about what was the impact on
you and your industry and at first did
you see it as like cool this is a new
thing I can use or at first was it like
usually when there's emerging technology
some people embrace it and some people
get very anxious about what it means to
the status quo so how did that go for
you yeah I mean I can only speak on
behalf of myself but I mean I've noticed
a huge shift in the industry
um just from that you know from the
content creators aspect from it being
out there people can literally film
themselves off their phones edit it
themselves upload it it'll Watermark it
you know be literally in control of
their own footage and sell it to the
consumer directly which wasn't a thing
when I got in the business and you know
as I say it is a benefit for people but
it's definitely had a bit of an impact
on the adult industry I'd say is
performing because people now have more
control over where they work who they
shoot for
um and I notice more people use it as a
promotional tool now they'll kind of
come and shoot for a bigger company
maybe to promote themselves and their
brand rather than just their of pages to
get their name more out there I see um
so I definitely think there's a good
aspect to it now people using the adult
industry to Market themselves on their
own platforms
um
but yeah as I say in terms of the
production values I think it's horses
for courses you know the people that
want to watch the big storyline stuff
are always going to want to watch that
big storyline stuff uh the people that
are looking for the cookie Hut cookie
cutter [__] of you know stuck in the
washing machine they're always going to
find it
um and I think if you want that more
one-on-one interaction with a performer
or with talent that option is now there
whereas it used to be sort of webcaming
based and you could kind of get that
real element of real-time interaction
um now with platforms like only fans the
consumers can get that whenever they
want it so I think it's just given more
variety to the industry and to the
consumer the consumer can now decide
what type of Pawn they want to watch and
what they enjoy
um whereas and there's only funds open
to I mean I know it's open to but can
mail performers have success too like
are you on only phones yeah I'm on only
fans um yeah I have great fun on there
um and again it's it's a great extension
for me to be able to work with my job
you know so there is certain scenes you
know as we were saying with the story
lines and elements and they're super fun
to do
um but sometimes there is a cool just
connection and you can just have that
raw chemistry no storyline no acting and
just that fun sex element for 20 30
minutes
um and I do enjoy that element that kind
of you don't always get with
professional porn just because there is
so much more involved and story based
and even during the sex you might be
trying to remain in character you know
and just come up with funny one-liners
or something that your character may say
you know
um do you ever get like because with
only fans we've talked to a few people
who've done only fans one of the things
that people often say is in general the
the feeling is overwhelmingly positive
but one of the things people sometimes
say is that because there's that
direct pay transaction going like where
there's somebody paying you directly and
you sort of know who it is sometimes it
can be a bit of a confusion from some of
the customers in terms of they think
there's a stronger connection there than
there actually is yeah
um yeah I can see that
um and I think again it's it's how
people buy into it and it's the I think
it's more down to the interactions that
they have rather than the sort of the
the transfer of cash okay
um I think they're able to have a
conversation with someone at all sorts
of hours of the day whereas when you
sort of join a subscription-based site
you know the videos released once a day
or once a week whatever it is and that's
kind of your interaction with the site
unless you go on a forum or more on
something whereas
even if they're on only fans if they're
sending you a video it comes with a
little description and a note and a
something personal while I was out the
other day with my friend and did this
this and this so I just feel that you
grow to know the character more sure you
know you you kind of get an insight into
their life but is it not that must be
quite invasive to you because if you are
doing stuff through a company like
brothers it's all set up they're
planning it out for you all that sort of
stuff if it's only fans and someone can
message you uh whatever time whatever
day from any country and say if you do
this I'll pay this amount is it not that
sense of that you have to be always
ready to just go actually if I just do
that I may as well just do that I may as
well just do that I think it's a really
good point you know because you can burn
yourself out and you see it a lot of
people be on it you know on it on it and
then they burn out you don't want to
even open the app anymore
um and I think it's really important to
set boundaries for yourself set working
hours
um some people do the fans sometimes
might request a lot you know they kind
of expect well I paid for this last
night or why didn't you answer you know
I'm paying my membership and it's like
it's like 4.99 a month like it you don't
own a person for 4.99 a month you know
you can't expect them just to be on
there 24 7.
um so as I say I think setting out it's
it's a difficult dynamic because
sometimes the customer might try and
push you a little bit to get something
but I think you just have to be quite
firm with yourself and say look I'm
going to stick to working hours you
can't take the piss you know you can't
let someone just wait three weeks to get
a response on a message but I think it's
it's both sides you know we have to
understand that the the user doesn't
want to wait days and days for a
response and the user kind of has to
respect that we're probably not going to
be living on the app for 24 hours a day
um so I think if there's a nice balance
and you can manage that or self-manage
that
it kind of keeps you in a bit more of a
better mental state to continue longer
rather than burning out that makes sense
it's actually a very similar story to
the one that we hear from you know
social media creators in terms of just
the you can always do more and more but
if you don't keep an eye on it you'll
suddenly hit that point where you can't
bear to do anything yeah
um so in general only fans for you you'd
say has just been a positive yeah um I'd
say it's a positive it's definitely sort
of given me a kick up the butt to kind
of change some of my own content and do
some extra things do ideas that I kind
of might have shelved before
um now I've got um Avenue I can release
them all yeah you know before it would
kind of be something I'd have to pitch
to a company and say hey we've got this
idea we fancy doing this
um whereas now we kind of have a lot
more creative control and kind of say to
the girl directly I hate you fancy doing
this idea or I've got this location do
you fancy splitting it and and we can
kind of create that together do you find
that the majority of the people that are
on your only fans are they male or
female mines predominantly male um I
have a small female fan base on there
but it's mainly guys so are they is it
because they like you as in looking at
you or is it that they're asking you to
do things to a female performer I think
a lot of it's because of the goals
um so obviously if you follow a girl's
page
you follow that girl you get all of her
updates um if you follow a successful
guy or a regular guy he works with all
the different goals you know you get a
lot of variety of different chicks with
that following the dude so it might kind
of seem strange but yeah I have a lot of
straight guys follow my page which
kind of seems strange the straight guy
would follow a male porn star but when
the logic of it and like they explain as
well no because on my page for example I
give out one free video every week so
you know there's every week they get a
new girl and then they can request other
girls on Twitter and Etc and tell the
girl to shoot with me and it kind of
just creates a bit more of a community
it makes that makes sense all right I'm
going to change direction a little bit
and um basically when we did the first
video with you ages ago now
um you were talking you told the story
about being in Germany and someone
seeing your penis and it'd be massive so
afterwards the crew had a look and I can
confirm it is very big uh so could you
make all the men listening and watching
feel a little bit better by talking
through some of the problems with having
a giant penis oh brilliant yeah all
right this is one that no one ever wants
to hear okay right no one ever cares
about big problems big problems the real
thing so in America mainly I'm going to
start there if you've been to America
they have different toilets right right
now they water level for some reasons
it's really high now this is the biggest
gripe I have and we still get it here
but you when you sit down to go to the
toilet
your penis sits
right now in England right just like
your missus has just bleach the bowl
oh yeah now I'm just I'm sitting on all
that I have to hold it up so if I sit
down I have to like just wow pinch an
inch and then hold it up otherwise it
just kind of sits in the bowl and in
America they have a high water level so
it just it just sits in there floating
around hey guys it's not nice right yeah
um better already sometimes you have you
can sit on it if you don't like adjust
yourself properly
um this is really embarrassing but they
they sell these pants right for people
with to basically lift their their
package out make it a bit more you know
presented if you like
but if you have a larger bit it works as
like a little kangaroo pouch and I can
just keep everything in there and it's
the I put them on as a joke and realize
that these are actually pans for people
with big penises it's the most
comfortable thing I've ever seen but you
can't wear them out okay because it just
presents everything here in a little
bundle you know but so yeah just for
loungewear loungewear but again more to
the point is pants can be an issue you
know boxer shorts if they don't have a
little pouch or some sort of area to
swimming trunks
yeah just speedos for a no-go I'm afraid
you're uh you're quickly removed from
the swimming center wearing speedos yeah
um but yeah silly things like that can
be a bit awkward or Grace gray
sweatpants that's another annoyance
because you're just
as you are but people think that right
you're excited yes
and you're not and there could be
scenarios where you don't want people to
think you're excited you know you're
walking through Center Parks or
something and everyone's like oh look at
him and you're like no I'm
completely relaxed at the moment so yeah
there are a few little big problems
along the way fair play
um and then so yeah changing direction
again
um like get away from Center Parks
[Laughter]
um because it seems like you would refer
to your experience in the industry as
being positive
would you ever would you tell people if
they came to you and said oh family
members for example young family members
or whatever and said obviously 18 19 and
said I'm really interested in this is
what I want to go into would you advise
people into it because you've had a
great experience or other areas where
you'd go look you need to think about
this properly it's 100 something you
need to think about right this is not
something you jump into I personally
wish I didn't start at 18. I think it
should be 21. right I think you should
just have a couple more years to become
wise and just know what you want to do
it does cut off a lot of stuff and
restricts a lot of stuff um you know for
example you can't go and work in a
school afterwards and things there is
certain restrictions
um I think it's just something you need
to be very aware of that it will be
there for the rest of your life
um you put a nude on the Internet or a
video on the internet it will be there
um as much as you think it you know
people have to go on the site to find it
and all that sort of stuff it comes out
people will send it and it's definitely
something you need to consider because
it will have a wider impact on your life
than what you think so although my POS
my experiences have been really positive
there have been a couple of negatives
along the way but the positives far
outweigh the negatives for me
um but yeah it's not a simple decision I
don't ever recommend anyone just jump
straight into the PornHub game
um I think it's something even down to
only fans you really need to consider
the whole thing implications what it
means for you for your family future job
prospects future children that you may
have future Partners you may have
um there are things that one day you can
have to sit down discuss be open about
and be happy to give your honest view of
why you did it and I think as long as
you're okay with yourself and you're 100
confident in your answers then then go
ahead and do it but you just really need
to be sure of what you're doing it makes
sense so it's individual basis go in
with eyes wide open yeah um at the end
of the day there's very few careers that
that don't disappear you know if you
wanted to be a hot dog vendor and it
didn't work out for a couple of weeks
you'd quit it you know with this it's
that everyone will know you as a hot dog
van death it's quite a nice analogy
isn't it with a hot dog today sure but
you know everyone would always know um
this one it it's out there so as I say
even if it's something you want to dip
your toe in
that scene will always be there and did
you say earlier you've got kids I do
have a trouble I do you've got a child
um do you would you are you now totally
open to this is who you are I'm
comfortable with who I am or when you go
to for example a parent's evening are
you thinking God I hope they don't they
haven't seen me on it is a difficult one
um I think you always have that and a
lot you always know that they may know
um it may be a talked about thing
um but again I think a lot of it's upon
me you know how I present myself how I
act in life and normal stuff can be um
is the definition of it you know but
there can be some awkward times you know
I said McDonald's the other day and some
guy came over and said oh sorry I know
you're all eating with your family and
that's right to get a quick picture oh
and it's like
it's cool but like now what do I say to
the kids like dude I mean like just this
why does he want a picture yeah you know
so it's um what do you say in those kind
of uh normally something random or you
know they like my car or something but
do you do the picture or do you say yes
it depends on the scenario if I can kind
of get away and I'll say I'll meet you
at the door or something then I'll I'll
definitely always try I never want to be
no on the same terms there's just that
there's a level of space
um that makes sense yeah I once told a
story about a guy who recognized me once
and he told his wife that I was a
reserve player for dagenham and
Redbridge which I thought was just it
was so clean it was so quick-witted you
know he's like oh Danny is all right
grab a quick phone photo I was like yeah
yeah let's have a selfie with him and
his wife comes around and she was like
who's that and just as they walked
around even though he's a reserve player
for dagging I'm a Red Bridge
right no one that knows the reserves
it's like it's genius you know so um but
I did have a guy the other week that
came out to me and I was with my kids
and he was like oh Reserve player for
Dagon reference mate how's it going and
I was like yeah I like that if we could
just make this a thing man yeah Red
Bridge guy easier for you it makes it a
lot easier fair enough and um I guess
what what what's the future for you but
also what's the future for the industry
obviously there's you know we've talked
about only fans but there's a lot more
immersive and uh emergent Technologies
on the horizon there's AI stuff there's
filters there's
um you know web3 whatever that means at
some point people figure it out
metaverse worlds but where do you see
you know your industry in all of that
you know adults always being at the
Forefront of Technologies and emerging
techs you know whether we look at you
know down to the DVDs VCRs all of that
sort of major plays have always kind of
been influenced by adult and I think
wherever technology decides to go
Pawn's always going to be have a toe in
it you know when we was looking at VR
and all this sort of stuff there's
always someone trying to do a bit of
adult out there with it I think adult
will literally emerge into any new space
whether that's web 3 metaverse VR AI
whatever you know humans we have this
weird obsession with sex and a curiosity
to it you know I think
chat GDP would be writing that erotic
novel soon you know it's it's all there
um and I think people will always try
and do things to to use any new
technology for their benefit but I think
eventually the ones that stick around
Pawn's always going to play a part you
know so they'll find a way to make it
work I think so um I don't think you're
ever gonna eventually you may but I
think the the current model of Pawn
isn't going anywhere just yet I think
how we consume it might change uh things
like only fans becoming more
um having more stars in their own right
rather than just the companies I think
having these content creator programs
where people can you know get to know
the stars and stuff I think that sort of
thing will be a lot better for the
individuals within the industry but
ultimately I think uh the industry will
be just fine I think they keep poddling
along keep emerging
new text keep along with it that's right
nice and I guess like one of my final
questions we've got a couple more but
one of my final ones is um
Pawn across the board not necessarily in
the UK but across the board America UK
everywhere there are places it has a bad
reputation
um as as being unsafe or you know things
like that where do you think that comes
from
ah I don't know where it comes from but
it's it's definitely a thing
um and I think
maybe it's just a lack of Education of
the industry
um it's like I say people don't want to
hear how great the porn star's life is
no one wants to hear how awesome that is
you know people want to hear the the
crap stories oh they're drug addicts or
this that or the other or they was
forced into it or coercion or
it doesn't sell I think with wider
education you kind of get more of a
knowledge of how things are and I think
it
within within any industry there's
charlatans there's bad eggs in any
business and I think if we was to you
know do that to any industry you can
have the same but I think porn isn't as
widely spoken about so it might be
difficult to kind of get rid of these
these older um
I know what I'm trying to say you know
these kind of stereotypes yeah to kind
of get rid of these more stereotypes uh
views that people like in your in your
experience has it generally been quite a
safe industry for the performers male
and female yeah it's only got safer and
safer I mean now we have like a 20 30
minute chat every single day with each
new talent doesn't matter if I've worked
with this girl 20 times we'll sit down
and say what do you want to do what are
you happy doing are you okay doing
kissing I have a list like two pages
long just of different sex acts of
things you want to do things you don't
want to do that everyone's in full
control now you know it's um yeah
there's a lot of
concentration put on the safety of
performers now you know we never want
anything to anyone to do anything
they're not comfortable with want
everyone to be happy and at the end of
the day proud of what they're making you
know it's um it's quite a vulnerable
environment you know you're putting
everything out the line you're strip
naked you're the bear you know you've
got cameraman everyone filming you it
can be quite an intimidating environment
so obviously we want anyone in that
scenario to be as happy and empowered as
possible makes sense the best possible
thing they can and going back to what
you said before about the the technology
and porn adult Industries will always be
alongside any emerging technology
it's kind of a funny thing isn't it that
the majority of people all humans no
matter what their background is or where
they come from enjoy sex
and a lot of people like to look at
other people having sex and with their
friends talk about sex why do you think
that a society is formed over the years
why has the porn industry become a taboo
area and talking about sex has become a
taboo area because you'd think if you
were looking at humans on paper and you
were designing Society you'd go right
yeah that's going to be a huge part of
their how they interact you know nights
out will be based around that and these
kind of things and you've got you've got
places like Amsterdam where obviously
with the red light district and in Japan
where they have the soaplands and it's
it's legal and it's unionized and all
that kind of thing
why do you think that in a country like
ours and and places like America or
Europe why do you think it's seen as
such a taboo subject across all genres
it's a great question I wish I had the
answer I think it's um I think it's just
not spoken about enough I don't know why
maybe it's because we're not sexy when
we do it you know no one's sexy when
they masturbate yeah like not many
people are sexy when they're having sex
like it's I don't know
um as I say I think it's it's it's not a
discussed about thing if you look at
just the amount of money the adult
industry takes in a year I couldn't even
guesstimate what it is how many billions
but if we look around the room and ask
everyone here who's ever subscribed to a
porn site I'd be surprised if one person
put their hand up like it it's something
you don't admit and I'll admit it I did
all right I subscribed but it's not
something people openly talk about or
even the myth you know and say oh I did
it I think because there is a stigma to
it a slightly embarrassing thing you
don't want your colleague at work to
picture you going home pulling your
pants down at the laptop and just
throwing yourself around the room it's
it doesn't appeal as like a oh wow
you're successful you're doing all right
for yourself aren't you it's it's seen
as like the lonely thing and even if you
did it with your partner you know it's
and I think there's a certain stigma
attached to that there's stigma attached
to girls maybe enjoying pornography for
whatever reason she could be deemed as a
[__] or something just because she
watches Pawn like it's ridiculous like
you know
and I think the more conversation there
is about porn the better I think too
many people where it's not spoken about
can see porn as like a reference guide
and it's it's really not a reference
guide on how to have sex right you know
but I think the more if you actually
spoke to a woman about that she would
probably say yeah I don't want you to do
any of that to me you know I mean but
for a guy we watch porn and we're like
oh yeah she's loving that she's probably
not you know the actress so as I say I
think more people speak about porn and
sex and stuff in general the better it
is and I've got two more questions one
of them and obviously I'm not going to
ask you it's a personal question but as
a as a ballpark two and a half inches
I already know that I looked it up but
the uh no the um
the um as a bot like is it is it an
industry people can make a lot of money
in you know is it an industry that if
people are successful in they can be
making 50 Grand a year 100 Grand 250
Grand because I think it's that's one of
those things that's not really spoken
about where people look at it and think
yeah I have no idea if a successful
performer will be in the top one percent
of earners or you know the bottom 10 of
it as it's just not something that's
really readily available yeah I mean you
can earn all right money in in porn I
think there is a misconception people
think we're like on football as salaries
I I probably am on about a dagenham and
Red Bridge Reserve salary uh so I don't
know what they earn but it's probably
about mine
um but yeah as I say and again down to
the content creator programs such as
like only fans that's changed the game
um whereas a performer would say get
paid once for their day they'd go and
shoot a scene get paid their day rate
for that scene and what what if I can
push you and obviously I don't want you
to say your private information but just
as an industry standard what would you
say was a day rate for a scene uh it
depends guys or girls new levels of
experience and stuff like that but
generally for a new Talent you could be
looking around a thousand to fifteen
hundred dollars a day something like
that
um
but that would pretty much be your
payment that's that's you for the day
obviously expenses and stuff are covered
but that would be it and that's how many
you can get in a month I suppose yeah
and then how many bookings you can take
Etc or if you're under contract how many
you're guaranteed Etc but then with
things like only fans you could say film
that same video on the day you don't get
paid a thousand upfront but you can sell
that video every day for the next seven
years
um you own it yeah and you may sell it
just once a month for 10 bucks and but
it's just working out what works out
better for you so some people can make
extraordinary amounts of money really
quickly
um and some people have to slogan work
and build a thing and as I say it's
trying to find a happy medium I think if
if you find an abundance of money coming
in too quickly it's probably not going
to be sustainable right and if you're
not bringing enough money on the regular
again it's probably not going to be
sustainable so
makes sense sticking in that happy
medium sure I've seen your personalized
license plate though
okay so I guess my last question really
is when you look back at your life and
the experiences you've had you've had
quite an unusual life an extraordinary
life
um what's something you you know you're
still young but what's something you've
learned so far would you say what's
something your life has taught you I
suppose just having fun and just being
happy it's you I've had jobs where I
hated and worked for Friday feeling and
that Friday feeling is it's amazing but
there's something different about that
you know when you go to work all day all
week and you hate your job and you're
living for the weekend
that's depressing and it's horrible and
I think the best thing I found was just
enjoying my life and I've now do
something that I absolutely love and I
have fun every day I don't mind working
weekends I don't mind working any day of
the week you know and it's not about the
sex it's about the thing that I do
um so I think that's just the most
important thing I've learned is just
having fun enjoying my time for what it
is
um
and yeah just just literally be honest
be happy
and with that I can't see it going too
far wrong sure makes sense
10 years time 20 years time still going
to be doing it hopefully I mean
hopefully they'll just wheel me out in a
little chair oxygen tank put the mask on
I'll apologize to the girl hey I'm so
sorry it shouldn't take you long
um and that'd be me and say I'll have
three subscribers on my only fans uh be
a niche but it will be a very niche
market uh hopefully but yeah as I say
um I'm just happy to keep doing this all
the time it's fun I'll keep doing it
great well look Danny um talked to a
couple of times and you're always very
interesting articulate and really good
at sort of shining a light on an
industry that's absolutely massive but I
think not massively understood no I
appreciate the opportunity and as I say
you guys always cover our industry well
so I appreciate it thanks very much for
coming in thank you my man
the most common things were things to do
with uh anal because uh bodies have
prostates and when they get stimulated
it's apparently very uh engaging
um oh so this is is this this is a male
client being stimulated yeah